Here we go.
Newspapers across
the country
are dropping the Dilbert
comic strip after its creator,
Scott
Adams, went on a stunning racist
tirade this weekend, calling
black Americans
a hate group
and advising white people
to stay away from them.
And as Polo Sandoval
has the story this morning for us, Polo,
good morning to you.
What's up? With this?
Yeah, guys, good morning to you.
So basically,
he is doubling down on the comments
that he made earlier this week saying
that they were completely
taken out of context.
The newspapers know that ran
his strip
for decades,
are now severing ties
with him,
saying that his comments
were part of a racist tirade
Yes.
You know,
nearly half of all blacks
are not okay with white people.
That's a hate group.
That was a comment that may have ended.
Scott Adams his newspaper career,
the Dilbert creator,
referencing a poll
from the conservative firm
Rasmussen Reports that indicated 53%
of black Americans agree
with the statement it's okay to be white
leading the other 47%
to say they disagree or aren't sure.
The Anti-Defamation
League has noted
that that phrase has a long history
in the white supremacist movement.
The best advice
I would give to white
people is to get the hell away
from black people.
He continued to double down
throughout his show,
The Washington Post, Los Angeles
Times and USA Today,
among the hundreds of newspapers
that denounced Adams
and quickly pulled Dilbert.
USA Today newspaper CEO Mike Read.
It was, frankly, an easy decision.
We found the remarks
hateful, hurtful,
and then just crossed the line.
But not everyone agrees.
Twitter CEO Elon Musk coming to Adams's
defense, tweeting, The media is racist.
Adams has since tweeted
that he was only advising people
to avoid hate and suggested
that the cancelation
of his cartoon
signals that free speech in America
is under assault.
We believe in free speech.
We believe in creating
a place for differing points of view.
But there's a line
that gets crossed where
things become racism.
And and that's not an area
we choose to
to traffic in or participate in.
But he rejected a company
that was responsible
for distributing that comic strip.
Still waiting to hear back, guys.
But have to tell you,
after watching hours
and hours of his latest
streams,
it's really hard
to gauge exactly how worried he is.
I'll tell you why he loves attention.
It's not me saying it.
He actually said it over the weekend
on one of his streams.
And he also recognized
that he was completely aware
that this was basically going
to open up the floodgates.
And when he made these
bombshell remarks,
so he is getting a bit of what he wanted.
But the question will it be
more than what he bargained for,
especially since he says that he expects
to lose a majority of the income
in the coming days? Right.
There are many times
when people are taken out of context
or they need explaining or whatever.
But his comments were
that's not what's with these comments.
He keeps saying
that's not what I meant to say,
but it is exactly what he calls
it, useful provocation.
He wanted to
start a conversation in guys.
But there are many ways
to start a conversation
about race in America
that doesn't include calling
black Americans what he called them.
So I think that this will be
certainly one to watch.
And as you continue
to hear major newspapers,
not just here in the U.S.,
but around the world, dropping the Strip.
What will he do next?
Yeah, and it's important to note
that the poll that started
all of this that he was talking about,
they are not talking about their data.
There are people have cast doubt on
how accurate it is
and what it looks like.
And if people are trying to vote on it,
to change the outcome of it.
So I think that's an also
an important context
of what he's even talking about
in the first place. Really?
Does he say he's being canceled?
Is that what he thinks?
That's what he says.
I wonder
if he's perhaps seeing himself
as sort of this free speech martyr.
Again, we'll have to see
as more of these newspapers
drop his work
after decades and for 30 years,
his speech comes with consequences.
Yeah. Thank you for that.